welcome home London
how you doing
good even in the darkest days of this
war his family prayed this moment might
come Aiden Aslan back safe at his mum's
house in Nottinghamshire
especially in the Saudis and
signed up to fight for the Ukrainian
military and spoke to Sky News in the
trenches earlier this year my fiancee's
Ukrainian
um I've got a house like in Ukraine I'm
building a family but that's been
captured by the Russians and threatened
with execution he was set free along
with four other British men and hundreds
of others in a prisoner exchange
brokered by Saudi Arabia
on their flight home Aiden was alongside
Sean Pinner from bedfordshire
of the danger zone and were on our way
home to our families
and they've smiled all day reunited with
his family Sean told Sky News that he
only found out about the release two
days ago they said you have to roll your
stuff up they said you're going on a
long journey we were moved to another
location we didn't have any idea what
was happening
many of those released had been captured
after The Siege at the steel works in
mariupole the other British men are John
Harding from Sunderland Andrew Hill from
Plymouth and 22 year old Dylan Healy who
is now back home in Cambridgeshire some
of my native had some training within
the military terms so they might be a
little bit better to cope with this
where whereas people like Dylan who have
had no training at all uh may may
struggle a bit but we don't know it's
just making sure that they get the right
support at the right time and they're
around family now so that's the main
thing
decompressing and readjusting to life in
Suburban Britain May well take time and
some of these men were living in Ukraine
with Ukrainian Partners before the war
broke out and some may choose to return
Aiden Aslan is back home with his
Ukrainian fiancee she said she was so
grateful and to every other family still
waiting she said don't lose hope
miracles happen to those who believe in
them
Tom Parmenter Sky News